i was talking to sal he said something
so bizarre
you were talking about in italy your
parents are from italy
yeah you would mail a letter in italy
yeah and it and what was it like
it was like russian roulette to get the
letter say it again slowly
russian roulette spell that rush
like in a rush yeah and roulette
when you would mail something from italy
it was like rush
and roulette yeah russian roulette so
you're saying
rush you're saying rush and
roulette what does that mean what does
that mean
it's a game where you put a bullet in a
gun and you spin it
and what is that game spell it to spell
it for me
rush spell rush rush rush and roulette
russia
rush like the rock band rush r-u-s-h
and a-n-d roulette r-o-u-l-e-t-t-e
now you say there is a game
there's a game called russian roulette
and you just heard the game yes the game
is where people put one bullet in a gun
and then and one person in the chamber
yep right they spin the chamber they put
the
the gun to their head and then they uh
pull the trigger hoping that the bullet
doesn't hit him so now why do you think
they call that game
rush and roulette
and a rush to play it i guess maybe
they're in a rush to play it what do i
care about russian
i'm telling you how lousy the male
system is there
you think i give a [ __ ] about russia
this is not about russian system
my dad it was russian roulette did he
get it did he not did he get them
this is a great analogy so when i was
talking to you guys
i said what what is the rush to play
roulette and that's what i mean
because i don't know maybe pick it up
rush it put the
uh bullet in in a rush and do it like
probably because
it's so scary and traumatizing let's
do it in a rush russian roulette put it
in rush it spin it
roulette click you know pull the trigger
boom
don't die where did you learn the term
rush
and roulette i don't know where you hear
it you hear it like anything else
like somebody played crap somebody
played i don't know somebody played
poker somebody
played russian roulette and killed
himself do i tell sal
or do i not even waste my breath no i
want you to tell
him you want me to tell him tell me what
have you ever heard of the salad
dressing
rush and dressing that's russian
dressing oh
dressing no it's rush and dressing
you don't know that i think i know where
you're going with this
where am i going you put it together
russian roulette russians
must have come from russia right i was
yeah yeah
there's a lot going on man sometimes you
forget [ __ ]
yeah sometimes you just don't know [ __ ]